we've got some breaking news um
three-time women's and champion boris
becker a sentence has been handed down
after he was found guilty of four
charges relating to his 2017 bankruptcy
let's go straight to our correspondent
charlotte lomas she's outside the court
um what is the sentence charlotte
we've just heard that boris becker will
be spending two years and six months in
prison now this is for count
four which relates to payments made
knowing the bankruptcy was in order and
the judge deborah taylor has said the
choice was not boris becker's to make
and a large sum has been lost to the
estate she went on to say that she
accepted boris becker was in a state of
chaos as a result of the bankruptcy
order but notable that there was no
remorse shown or any acceptance of your
guilt there has been no humility
so count for two years and six months in
prison there was also for the lesser
charges 18 months which will be served
concurrently so we have heard from
inside court that boris becker has now
picked up his hold all that he brought
into the courtroom now been taken from
the witness box the former three times
wimbledon champion will now spend two
and a half years in jail
okay charlotte thank you very much